ADAM GLAZIER: Hi.
I'm Adam Glazier, a UX designer
on the Google Cast team.
If you're new to
Cast, Cast is a way
for people to get content
from your app to their TV.
In this video, I'll show you
why Cast works the way it does,
so that you can be informed
while designing your app.
Now, for the sake of
simplicity, the examples
I'll share focus on Casting
and controlling video.
However, it's worth
noting that you can also
Cast other types of media, such
as music, photos and games.
When designing for Cast, there's
three main things to consider.
First, your app is the remote.
So just like a TV
remote, your app
should make it easy for anyone
to control a Cast at any time.
People need instant
control, no matter
what state their device is in.
Second, it's a
shared experience.
When your app's casting, expect
that others are in the room.
Some will be watching,
some will contribute,
and some will need
to take control.
The third is that
it's cross-platform.
The living room has
many devices in it,
and the more devices that
can control your Cast,
the more seamless it will feel.
Because casting is a
new action, its usage
depends on people being
reminded that it's available.
An easy way to do this
is to show a one time
Cast introduction screen.
This intro helps
users new to Casting,
and it also helps experienced
users know that your app is now
Cast enabled.
Additionally,
placing the Cast icon
at the top right of
every screen in your app
allows users to start and
control casts at any time.
And to be clear, the
Cast icon should always
be visible whenever the
Cast receiver is available.
Once users are ready
to cast, there's
two ways they can connect.
They can connect to a Cast
receiver and then play content,
or they can start
playing content
and then connect to a receiver.
Either way, they start
Cast as a mode of the app.
So just like Bluetooth,
once you're connected,
whatever you play in the
app should Cast to the TV.
Now, once content starts
streaming to the TV,
the phone allows users to
browse and control Casts
while the TV displays
the streaming content.
So when designing
your TV UI, do not
make it look touchable or
simply reuse the tablet UI.
For example, in research
I have observed,
people attempted to use
the actual physical TV
remote when the UI on the
TV looked interactive.
So with this in mind, when
you tap pause on the phone,
it should change to a
play icon, but the TV
should show a paused icon.
This is because the TV is
showing the state paused,
and the phone is providing
the action to play.
The second tip is to help the
TV UI stay out of the way.
For instance, people
will sometimes
pause a video to examine a frame
or read text on the screen,
like closed captions.
So when someone pauses a
video, fade the TV UI away
after 5 seconds.
Keeping the UI within the
lower fourth of the TV
will also help, since most
of the important content
is typically above that.
And the last tip is
to provide the ability
to control a Cast from
every state of your app.
At any given time, the most
critical controls for people
are play and pause and volume.
Remember, this is
super important,
because your app is the
only remote they have.
Now, for Android there's five
places to surface controls.
You could provide a full
set of controls in your app
for the content
currently playing,
and when navigating
elsewhere in your app,
provide a persistent controller.
This is commonly a control bar
at the bottom of the screen.
Also provide controls
within the Cast menu,
because this is where users
start and stop Casting.
And when users
exit your app, make
sure to provide controls
in the notifications
and the lock screen.
Doing all of these together
will ensure the most seamless
experience so your
users can relax and use
their phone however they like.
Now, once something is
casting, expect that more users
will want to join in.
At a minimum, when multiple
users are connected,
each user should be
able to take control.
An example of this
is that you just
left the room while
Casting, and your friend
needs to take control.
Another possibility is that you
started a Cast and your friend
wants to add to the queue.
So designing your app to
work for anyone at any time
will help it feel extra natural.
Now, from time to time, expect
that the phone's connection
to a Cast may go in and out.
This can happen from
the Wi-Fi going out
of range, the battery
dying, or your app's process
is being stopped by another app.
When this happens,
automatically reconnect
users that dropped off
whenever they're in your app.
And the final step to a
Cast is disconnecting.
Users can disconnect
from the Cast menu
or from a notification
in Android.
To prevent users from
accidentally stopping a Cast,
only stop the Cast when the
last connected user disconnects.
For the complete set
of Cast UX guidelines,
don't forget to check out the
design checklist on the Cast
SDK site.
Thanks for watching, and
I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]